I get tattoos because for me they're
reminders reminders of things in my life
where things I've accomplished or wished
to accomplish the first tattoo that I
ever got was the one on my left hand
that says happy wife happy life because
I I mean this [ __ ] is real I actually
got it before I got married I just knew
I loved the woman that I was with and I
felt really good about that because as
much success that you could have or
money financially being stable amassing
fans millions of people who know who you
are it is all nothing without someone to
share it with balance yourself I taught
my right hand because I'm like a
workaholic and I like to do so I have
like so much stuff going on it's crazy
like insane and beyond just music as
well as like film and writing and I just
finished my first novel I started my
second then I started a record company
and starting a production company and
doing all these different things it's
like you got a chill out you know
because you don't want to burn yourself
out and you want to make sure that you
can enjoy all the things that you've
worked so hard to attain I have no idea
why the first time I ever got a tattoo
was on my hands that's like something
real like gangsta [ __ ] in many ways I
think it's like a great reminder you
know you look down and you see it and
you're like oh yeah
chill out oh yeah you know make sure
your wife is happy because you'll be
happy the logo for my album everybody so
if you look at it it's like an e write
for everybody but if you turn it to the
side it's my third album so it's a Roman
numeral for three and I just thought it
was pretty bitching
this on my left wrist is actually a bit
of like a double one or the shorter one
its kanji for Kill Bill and Kill Bill is
fourth film by Quentin Tarantino which I
absolutely love
Tarantino's my favorite writer and
director without that movie I would not
have truly discovered hip hop and I say
that because the RZA from wu-tang clan
actually scored the film and through
discovering the RZA I discovered wood
Tang Clan through discovering Wudang
clan and discovered nas mos def Tribe
Called Quest Big L I mean it goes on and
on and I got these in Tokyo Japan which
I always wanted to go to because of Kill
Bill honestly it's probably my most
meaningful to me personally and this one
here says its kanji versus ultra 85
which is an album I will be working on I
got it because I was kind of working on
it a bit while I was in Japan and it
just means so much to me so I don't know
I was just like Yolo let's do it let's
get it turn up
swag flex dad's logic
[Music]